we are keeping it country with uh power
couple marin morris and ryan hurd who
enjoyed a glamorous date night at the
acm awards where they were the first
couple to be nominated in the same year
since tim mcgraw on faith hill now we
need to take a moment for their
coordinating outfits love this love it
very much
[Laughter]
okay all right all right it's the hip
for me yes uh marin is actually wearing
a vintage leather dior dress from 2000
telling reporters it felt kind of
western but still millennial as for ryan
he admitted it's all marin who sets the
tone and he just follows along
i am concerned about those ties because
i feel like that is an accident waiting
to
right like what if like
that's a that's going to be a thank you
i love it now
just a few days before the show marin
proudly showed off her post-baby bod as
she posed in a skin-tight dress with
this caption
in this house we stand mom bellies
yes nearly two years after giving birth
to her son hayes marin continues to
spread body positivity and has been very
outspoken about learning to love herself
postpartum back in may maren told people
magazine i feel like it really took me a
second to realize hey i don't need to
just snap back to how i look before to
feel sexy or powerful or even myself
marin also shared a candid post back in
april about the body pressure that women
face after pregnancy
writing in part
i am never saying trying to get my body
back again no one took it i didn't lose
it like a set of keys the pressure we
put on mothers to snap back is
insurmountable and deeply
troublesome
ugh i agree
i agree
i've you've
had children i haven't had children but
i'll just say
i don't know why i'm giving my two cents
child but what i'll just say is the
pressure for women in their bodies is
insane
i feel so bad it's like you bring life
into this world literally the most
precious thing that you can do
and instead of it just being celebrated
and like give the woman the world we're
like oh but is her body perfect you know
to these societal standards like what
she gave life who cares why do you even
have these standards so i just the whole
thing is just insane to me and what we
deem as sexy what we deem is beautiful
all of that is a mess but i i'm i'm
happy that more women are speaking about
body positivity because it's important
girls
do so much damage to themselves there's
so much body dysmorphia so many issues
with mental health people go through so
much because of what society says is
beautiful and them not feeling like they
can amount to that it's like it's not
cool so you know let's change what that
looks like yeah i remember
after i decided i was going to come back
to work after six months and i was going
to hit the grammy red carpet after four
months and i was standing beside coco
rocha the model
she was one of the co-hosts
and i just remember being like i need to
get it together and i and i worked so
hard but then i realized and i only
realized this years later keisha i did
that to myself
there was no one at work telling me i
needed to be a certain size there was
there wasn't there was no one and i
think that all of this starts in here
for women i really do we can blame
everyone else but it really has to do
about where we're comfortable and and
and how we feel about ourselves
i think that there's also this part
though we were talking about this in the
in the meeting this morning
you live 30 some years with a body that
you know right and you're comfortable in
it and then you have a baby
and then you say to yourself
i want to get back to that body because
i'm comfortable in that body because
that's the body i know
if that is you right if that is you and
you want to get back to that that should
also not be shamed
if you're comfortable in the new body
and that's where you want to stay that
should be celebrated also but i think
there needs to be a beautiful kindness
for women depending on where you fall on
that spectrum
kindness on all of it because it really
is up to the woman and really we can't
blame anyone else because we set the
standard for ourselves i blame me for
pushing myself the way i did to do it in
an irrational time now second baby
around
she was six before i got it all off i
got real comfortable and i was like no
no no six is fine six four months isn't
doable but six years is totally fine
it's just so much it is so much pressure
so it i do think it's important for
celebrities to speak out about
postpartum bodies because we see a lot
of celebrities who get you know the best
of everything and they get the photoshop
they get the filters they get the you
know they get all the glam the facials
the team the glam squad and we have this
idea trainers what
yes the nutritionist the everything and
the surgeries and the things that they
don't want to admit to yeah and we see
this and we're like wait why don't i
look like that and then it affects you
but you don't realize that it's all
smoke and mirrors so i do think that
celebrities have a responsibility if you
want to be glam i love my instagram i
love to be glam but you know what i'm
gonna show you the realness i like
everyone should be responsible for
showing like well this is what i
actually do yeah this is how i do it so
i i think that we need
yes so let's be honest all around yeah
okay uh we have a comment here we are
still we have one comment but we do
sorry we just threw up in the thing here
yes um not threw up but you know what i
mean tia says no one show it off girl
your body housed another human just like
keisha said it is a literally a temple
for life a temp i am a yes tia i am a
temple tia
okay
not this type of temple why did i do
genie in a bottle i don't know but it
worked for what in the christina
aguilera